to an updated office tour guys you've
been requesting this for quite some time
and basically making this because I am
very shortly going to be redoing my
office yet again just when I get it to
the point where I'm super excited I love
how it's working out I go and get crazy
and make some changes so right now this
is my current office setup that I have
when you first walk in this is my
unboxing station so we've got three
lights you've got two light panels one
two and we've got this light Matt plus
four which I am obsessed with this is
all future things that I need to unbox
this is fire hazard and here's a little
area where I charge a bunch of batteries
so yeah spoiler alert here's the
electrical tape that I used to take my
microphone in my body it's pretty
painful here's the scissors that I used
to cut the electrical tape to put the
microphone on my body
he's the two cameras that I used to do
all of my unboxing stuff here at this
desk these are the a7 s twos so on this
main camera I'm using an 18 to 35 but
actually I usually use a 25 to 270 but I
was traveling and I took that one with
me and I haven't replaced it I've been
rotating my second camera out with my a7
three but I'm filming with it right now
on this one is a thirty-five millimeter
but in most of my newer videos I've been
using the 18 to 105 have a small HD
focus right here this one is one of
their newer ones and I love it cuz it is
touchscreen and it's also super small
and tiny for travel now right here we've
got another small HD I'm recording all
this video live so I'm kind of filming
and talking at the same time that's why
it might be a little bit silly I've also
got knives stashed pretty much every
place that you could imagine because
obviously when you do a lock seams you
need to have some good knives super
dangerous super safe as we venture away
from the unboxing desk we have my dog
Maddy
hi Maddy do you want to play some Xbox
do you wanna play Fortnight Maddy what
do you thing about fortnight
this is where I play xbox it's sitting
extremely close to the couch because I
like the lounge here the Xbox is
actually under the couch I'm not really
proud of this setup but it's extremely
comfortable and sometimes I will
actually game on my lg tv back here but
when I'm playing first-person shooter
games I much rather prefer sitting on
the couch lounging and sitting very
close to a TV so I don't have to have my
contacts in it makes sense in my mind so
I've divided my room into two sections
this over here is the PC side and this
is the Mac side over here on the Mac
side we've obviously got two of my
favorite drinks we've got Lacroix yerba
mate eh this thing is kind of cool it
does connect to a LEF say we've got an
echo spot a nice candle hard drive with
a 3d print of my dog and three of my
favorite lego minifigures we've got
Benny we've got Steve Jobs and myself of
course the 18 Cormac which I am obsessed
with this razor mouse pad is probably
one of my new favorites oops the best
photo ever of me Jena and Susie in
Hawaii and there's another hard drive
back there of course more hard drives
original iPhone home pod play me some
music tuning in your personal radio
station you know what's it gonna burst
up Taylor Swift oh okay
moppy wireless charger and of course
each side of the office is quite readily
equipped with a Star Wars lamp these are
all hue lights so I can change these
colors very easily with my phone so in
the middle here is just this
entertainment console which I don't
entirely have set up yet we've got a
printer which I fight with quite
frequently
we've got my favorite collectable Xbox
360 this is the Star Wars one and it's
so cool of course the white Xbox console
because sometimes my sister and I both
sit on this couch we game together so we
set up a duel station
this isn't all entirely set up yet
because I do want to take my playstation
and put this under here the Xbox that's
under the couch will also go here when I
play on the TV just forget about that
one more really terrible cable
management thick PlayStation Pro I've
got my surface keyboard and this
actually doesn't belong over here that's
my Mac keyboard surface Mouse surface
travel Mouse microphone for when I need
to record vo of pier this is actually
really cool this is one of the stream
decks and this is a white stream deck
it's a concept
most of the stream decks that they have
now are black so they sent me this white
one and they're like what do you think
and I said I love it
it matches my aesthetic perfectly you
guys saw me unboxing the pink razor
accessories before in another video I
think it looks so good like it looks
great I absolutely love the look of it
what's looking for me you see me I'm
looking at you didn't get lower
I'm sure to go look at bottom so here's
the stream deck turned on what do you
guys think of the white I think it looks
great you look so beautiful
of course the lilac s9 to match the pink
aesthetic over here here's to archive
drives that are full of just random
goodies and here's my surface book this
thing I've been traveling everywhere
with in addition to my macbook and using
it to play for tonight shoes shoes but i
forgot to mention my mini consoles
they're so beautiful when i do want to
play these i just move them right over
to here hey Maddie you need to be more
excited about this movie that we're
making did you just wink at me oh my god
you just winked here is my travel
backpack chairs
oh this over here is a future video this
is one of my Mac books from 2006 um one
last thing we've got this cabinet of
magical goodness there's a bunch of
random things with a tripod surge
protector
please Asian accessories snapshots
sunglasses mm gopro harddrive charges
intend to accessories gaming audio
microphones lots of HDMI lots so in here
we've also got more chords my Apple
watch bands Apple watches
I love the Google clips iPhone 3GS box
lots of power bricks phones phones
phones phone cases audio accessories
this is also another future video I'm so
excited about it this was a past video
get into it more various accessories
we've got travel adapters like magic
gizmos webcams and here is really have
all of my cables organized by moments
upside down micro USB miscellaneous mini
USB see and under there is some more
here's some travel bags backup headset
Wow that's it good bye well thank you
guys for watching I have absolutely no
idea what this video looks like because
I'm filming it and the microphone that I
have on here is extremely heavy so I
feel like I've been shaking this whole
time trying to hold this tripod and this
camera and this microphone up at the
same time anyway I just want to show you
guys my office you guys always are
asking about what I've made changes to
and what my current workspace looks like
so this is it it will be changing very
soon but I'm very excited about the
changes hopefully it'll be sooner than
later
Wow I don't if you guys heard that but
he just let out a huge sigh I'll see you
guys in my next video
[Music]